Hi everyone. Today at Port Swigger we're celebrating the fact that one million people
have made use of the Web Security Academy. It's 13 years since I first wrote the Web Application
Hackers Handbook and the second edition followed a few years later. Lots of readers asked if there
was going to be a third edition. Writing a book comes with some serious downsides. You do a lot
of work at once and then it immediately starts to become obsolete. It's printed on paper so it's not
interactive and you can't google for the contents and people have to pay to read it and most of that
money goes to the publisher anyway. So instead of a third edition of the Hackers Handbook, here at
Port Swigger we decided to make something that is digital, online, actively maintained, interactive
and completely free. Enter the Web Security Academy. We launched the Academy a year ago and we've
continued building it ever since. Today we cover a wide range of topics like XSS, SQL injection,
cores, server-side template injection, request smuggling and many others. We have nearly 150
interactive labs which you can access instantly. These contain real vulnerabilities just like the
bugs that you find in the real world so you can safely and legally develop and hone your skills.
All the labs have clear solution steps in case you get stuck and need a little help. You can track your
progress as you work through the learning materials and as you solve the labs you'll be rewarded with
different levels of achievement from apprentice through practitioner to expert. Many of our labs are
fiendishly difficult and will stretch even the most seasoned penetration testers. Sometimes we struggle
to solve them ourselves. There are halls of fame where you can see how you're doing compared to other
people across the world and we have regular competitions where you can win some great swag.
The Web Application Hackers Handbook sold 100,000 copies in 10 years and when we launched the Web
Security Academy we set an ambitious goal to reach 1 million people in our first year. That's 10x in 1
tenth of the time and today we've reached that milestone which is really amazing. It's fantastic to
be reaching a new generation of web security testers and helping them learn how to find vulnerabilities
and also to be helping experienced penetration testers, researchers and security engineers
take their game to the next level. Some bug bounty hunters have received big payouts using techniques
that they honed on the Web Security Academy. But this is only the beginning. We're going to carry on
building the Web Security Academy. We're going to be adding some exciting topics soon like deserialization
vulnerabilities and we'll be adding methodology content so you can learn how to become a security
tester or a researcher and everything will stay completely free forever. Do follow us on twitter
at WebSec Academy to be the first to hear about new topics and labs and to play in our regular competitions.
And if you haven't discovered the Web Security Academy already, please do check it out. We'd love to hear
your ideas and feedback.
Thank you.